[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  spinning like [ __ ] today man look what I  mean  [Music]  to be around here [ __ ] up [ __ ] Sheryl  Crow looking public what this is awesome  never been in a car like that's how's  mama come before there's so cute then we  get the age before guys become dicks you  think you're pretty cool too ghetto ass  friends you good  you think you're tough and [ __ ] give  this a little [ __ ] kid a lot of the  time you feel like our lives are the  worst but think if you look at anybody  else's closet  you ain't ray your [ __ ] for their [ __ ]  so let's go that's why we ride up he's  some food  what that does to somebody's spirit  Stevie what the [ __ ] are you doing  yo Stevie buggies change  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]